ah ça y est encore une technique qui fut
d'eau deux fois par an noël chic et se
livre à cet exercice périlleux attraper
les gros mal de 70 kg pour partir à la
tout cet ancien commercial est devenu
éleveur de chèvres angora à 55 ans
depuis ils leur voue une vraie passion
sa spécificité je dirais c'est d'avoir
une laine un poil qui pousse abondamment
ce qui permet de les tondre tous les six
mois et d'avoir un poil qui fait au
moins douze centimètres à peu près à la
tente
ce qui permet de faire une bonne laine
mohair qui va qui va être solide pour la
tonte noël sous traitent à des
professionnels l'opération est délicate
la chèvre angora à une peau très fragile
et de la laine jusque sous les pattes on
n'aime pas ça mais sans la tonte ann
moore est un animal qui a été
sélectionnée à partir d'animaux sauvages
et du coup à partir de cette sélection
n'a créé des agneaux qui ne perdent
jamais leur laisse donc si on les tons
pas la laine s'arrête jamais de pousser
ça finit par les empêcher de se déplacer
correctement de se nourrir correctement
il peut y avoir des parasites qui
s'accumulent dedans donc en fait c'est
très important de les tondre deux fois
par an une fois collectés la laine de la
chèvre et triés et nettoyer une étape
essentielle pour garantir la douceur du
moins le premier geste est de regarder
sur la ligne de dos si nous trouvons du
jard lejard est un poil on va dire un
peu dénaturé qui est raide que c'est
celui qui va gratter ce tri et la
sélection des bêtes c'est la spécificité
du mohair français qui ne représente
qu'un pour cent de la consommation
nationale
tout le reste vient d'afrique du sud la
laine part dans une filature pour être
lavé card est éteinte et elle revient
sous forme de pelote là c'est nadine qui
officie avec ses aiguilles le mot art on
est dans du de la qualité le plus haut
parce que s'il n qui est très douce qui
est hyper légère qui est très très
chaude donc on n'a pas plus doux que le
que le mot heures à la ferme en vente
directe ou sur les marchés noël et
nadine commence à vivre du mohair avec
les lapins angora et leurs deux alpagas
le couple est devenu incontournable dans
l'haleine haut de gamme made in france